>> Okay, so inheritability it deals with the difference in height and how
much of that variation is genetic but how do we figure that out?
>> I thought you might ask that question. So I
asked my friend Taylor to come in and help us out.
>> If you want to find out whether or not
a trait is influenced more by genetics or more by
environment, then you need to find a pair of people
who are identical. And see if they both have that trait.
>> So, you mean like twins.
>> Identical twins to be exact.
>> Oh wow, you creeped me out.
>> We get that.
>> A lot.
>> Identical twins are actually a really
useful tool for scientists to determine heritablity.
>> But aren't there different types of twins?
>> Well there are. there are identical and there're fraternal
twins. We also refer to them as Monozygotic and Dizygotic.
>> Wait mono what?
>> Monozygotic and dizygotic.
>> Oh.
>> Monozygotic means that they came from same fertilized egg or zygote.
Dizygotic means in a came from two different fertilized eggs or two different
zygotes. So genetically identical twins, do you
think they would be dizygotic or monozygotic?